[Musique]
quelles plantes associées à noël porte
le nom d'un homme politique américain
le poinsettia joël hourbeigt 27 a été le
premier ambassadeur américain au mexique
pottas nist aguerri il importe sept
plantes à floraison hivernale aux états
unis dans les années 1820 considérée
comme l'une des fleurs exotiques les
plus belles du monde
le poinsettia est une forme ces plantes
sont particulières parce que leurs
fleurs n'ont ni pétales ni cepal ce qui
donne au poinsettia sa couleur rouge ce
sont ses bractées celle ci ressemble à
des feuilles mais elles sont en fait à
mi chemin entre une feuille est une
fleur à l'origine le poinsettia est un
arbuste tropicale qui peut atteindre
jusqu'à 5 mètres de hauteur les
poinsettias était d'ailleurs vendu comme
fleurs coupées au début du 20e siècle
grâce à l'hybridation et à la sélection
l'arbuste peut aujourd'hui se vendre en
pot on trouve plus d'une centaine de
cultivars différence sur le marché les
hybrideurs développe sans cesse de
nouvelles couleurs mais année après
année c'est le rouge qui domine les
ventes aujourd'hui dans le monde les
plus grands producteurs se trouve en
californie et en allemagne au canada
c'est l'ontario qui produit environ la
moitié des poinsettias du pays devant la
colombie-britannique et le québec
m
[Musique]